hello everyone this game was played in
1968 so some four years before Bobby's
match of the century against the Boris
Spassky in Reykjavik and Bob is playing
against Anthony sayyidi Anthony said it
was a strong international master he was
also a chess order and he was somewhat
of a friend to Bobby Fischer as Bobby
Fischer did stay with him and his family
right before he went to play his match
of the century and Anthony said he was
actually one of the people that that are
responsible for talking him into
actually going to Reykjavik to play the
match so sight is white here and Fischer
is black let's see this game we have C
for the English opening by sight 85 by
Fischer Knight to c3 Knight to c6
we have g3 and the future plays f5
Bishop to g2 nice to f6
we have d3 Bishop to c5 III and here a
fish replace a move that is well
probably black to come up with a better
move but Bobby knows what it's doing as
this will this will allow black a
dynamic game we have e captures on f4
and Fisher castles and we have nigt e2
Queen to e8 and side e castles d6 and we
have Knight to a4 now attacking this
Bishop on c5 and the Fischer plays a
Bishop to d4 as the Fischer would much
rather as he does have to exchange this
Bishop before night he would much rather
exchange it on d4 down on c5 or mb6
as you'll see after Knight capture
Sunday for each capture Sundy for this
Knight is looking pretty silly here on
a4 as the C for the C 3 square is no
longer available for him and he doesn't
really have a bright future here on a4
there's a famous saying knight on the
rim is grim I always like to remember
this one society plays h3 not allowing
any Bishop to g4 ideas we have h5 by
Fischer and now a3 we have a 5 and B 3
now an outside is trying to get this
Knight into the game as with
me too and who knows where he'll go from
there we have Queen to g6 and when the
screen to g6 move Bobby is turning all
of his wrath to this d3 pawn
we have Knights to be to now protecting
the d3 pawn and the bishop to f5 again
attacking the d3 pawn we have Queen to
c2 Knight to d7 and now rook to e1 as
this is preparing Bishop to f1 to add
another defender that is d3 pawn fish
place tonight to see 5 so again
attacking the d3 pawn and Bishop to f1
now defending the d3 pawn and this is a
position that really shows why Fischer
is king as well a lot of people would
try and move like rook to e8 here and
try to control the e-file and maybe
exchange a pair of Brooks
but first play something that is
somewhat counterintuitive but it's
actually brilliant he plays rook to a6
and this seems like it's putting the
rook out of the game but it's really not
as you'll see slightly plays Bishop to
d2 and we have a rook to b6 by Fischer
now attacking this b3 pawn and here sigh
any plays at Bishop captures a knife on
a5 and ok this doesn't really hang a
bishop because if Knight captures then
the simple before move wins the piece
back
so after this Bishop captures on a five
more Fischer plays rook captures on b3
we have Bishop back 32 and now Fischer
plays rook to 8 with another rook we had
a 4 and now the other group goes to a 6
as well so Ruby a 6
we have a 5 and psy.d is not allowing
Bobby to play rock the b6 as this would
be devastating we have King to h7 and
now rook to d1 and how Fischer plays b6
he really wants to put it out of rockin
to be B 6 v square and well capturing
this pawn isn't really a good idea is
real capture some b6 would be great for
black as we said so slightly plays a
bishop to e1 we have B captures on a5 we
Knight to a4 and here's Bobby's idea
that he had he was a rookie actress and
III sacrificing the exchange but not
really as this is only temporary
we have better characters on d3 Bishop
captures on d3 with an attack on the
Queen and now Queen to a2 and now Knight
the b4 and well the Queen doesn't really
have a good square
wherever the Queen goes the Knight has
has a jump to follow and capturing the
knightwood Bishop to b4 results in a
capture some before and then this knight
is pinned and this would be great for
black so we have a queen to a3 and now
Knight C to attack in both Queen and the
rook on a1 Queen to be 2 and now Knight
captures on a1 rook captures anyone and
Knight captures an a4 rook captures an
a4 and we have rooked Queen to e4 sorry
and this Queen 34 move is now attacking
this Bishop only 1 but this isn't the
main threat the main threat is rook to
b6 rook to b6 with an attack on the
Queen and then rook to be 1 and this
would be crushing
so here Saida tries one last idea
he plays Bishop captures on a5 not to
allow the rook to come to b6 but it
doesn't really matter as this allows a
different tactic official plays rook
captures on a5 so what doesn't really
have any moves here as he is down a
piece he plays rook captures on a5 and
is here the simple between the e1 check
King has to go to h2 and simply Queen
captures on a5 and fisheries up a piece
and this is completely winning for black
so in this position side he resigns the
game so yeah definitely a beautiful game
Fischer was really up to playing good
chess on this day and well yeah he
definitely shows that he is the king of
positional play so and that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon